i love monsters inc and i love mike
wazowski
sorry
i had to do it first thing we need to do
for this cake is make our little domes
so i have this cute little mold spray it
with some cooking oil
i'm going to put this on a baking sheet
in the oven at 350 degrees fahrenheit
for about 14 minutes i'm going to check
it at 10. okay i've got our cakes
they're out of the oven they are nice
and cooled we are gonna make a white
chocolate ganache that's gonna go over
the top we'll add some white chocolate
chips
one can of condensed milk
three tablespoons of butter i'm gonna
put this in the microwave for about 60
to 90 seconds
once you get that out of the microwave
it should be
nice and kind of ribbony so the last
thing we have to do is add some food
coloring all right i think that green
looks good
so now it is time
to pour
looks good
so we're just gonna keep going while
this is still warm
all right so while we let those guys set
i'm gonna dye some buttercream purple
blue and black last thing i have to prep
are candy melts i believe they use a
white candy melt for mike's eye and for
his horns
so i am going to just slice one in half
and that will make his little ears horns
things now it is time to put
one of these bad boys together
[Music]
he looks good he's so cute i love him so
much
all right i'm sorry mike
there wasn't too much ganache i really
liked it okay i really liked it am i the
mic to your sully like are you silly and
i'm like no you're sully no i'm like
i'm short and i'm pointing now i'm like
maybe physically i'm bigger than you but
i'm not i'm not able to scare children
as well as you probably are
so rude get out
get out
[Music]
[Music]
laughs
[Music]
oh
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh yes
[Music]
you